HIV / AIDS has taken the lives of more than 39 million people around the world, despite our efforts to prevent
Better treatment and understanding. But with 35 million people currently infected, exactly what
Is it, and are we approaching a cure?
To capture HIV, the virus must enter the bloodstream - and often have been transferred
Of infected body fluids such as blood, semen, vaginal fluids or breast milk.
Just enter the bloodstream, for a disease targeting a variety of cells, but more specifically
T cell helper (CD4), which is a type of white blood cell that plays a fundamental role
In our immune system and fight infections. The outer envelope of HIV is covered by sugary proteins
Which mutates frequently and ultimately fools the T-cell into not recognizing
The virus, just attacking specific proteins on the T-cell begin to remove the membrane
Together, the cell eventually enters where 2 RNA viruses are excreted and 3
Basic replication enzymes
Because HIV is a reverse virus, RNA transcribes to DNA, represented here from the clouds
Two RNA lines are converted to DNA and then this DNA has been combined
And add it to the cell genome, this makes the T cells treat the virus as its own, which causes
Which makes them make more copies of the virus and then leave the host cell full growth, and ultimately
To get more T-Cell, the virus is difficult to treat because of the change
Very high, and comprehensively the replication process creates more than 10 billion new viruses each
day
During these initial stages of replication, the stage of latency is called, the infected person may not appear
No symptoms for 8 years, if not eventually treated HIV HIV kills them
When T cells are less than 200 cells per cubic millimeter
Of the blood, becomes infected with AIDS or AIDS.
After this progress, the immune system becomes less and much more vulnerable
To cancer and opportunistic infections such as pneumonia. A person does not die of AIDS
In fact they die from any disease the body can not repel
At present there are medicines that help to combat opportunistic infections, such as Daraprim
Which was recently in the news when pharmacist Martin Shkreli decided to
Raising the price of $ 13.50 to $ 750 per pill medicine, there are also antiviral drugs that
Slow the virus by blocking certain enzymes that are required for the virus to multiply
Similarly, those without HIV but at higher risk of HIV infection may take pre-exposure
Prevention or PrEP. This works along the lines of antiviral drugs by blocking the enzyme
Reverse transducer.
Fortunately there is hope for treatment, there are few people who have immunity from HIV (AIDS)
Virus due to mutation associated with T cells. In one case, and on a positive HIV theme
For the bone marrow transplant, this means they have been given new stem cells that generate
T cells were different, and within 20 months there was no evidence of the virus being present in the bloodstream.
Although this drug is very unique, it certainly opens up possibilities
Generation of HIV-resistant cells, combining this with other treatments and preventive measures
Such as condoms, clean needle programs, safe blood transfusions, and perhaps one day HIV / AIDS
Be something of the past
Your video sharing is greatly appreciated, try to help know the spread and
Awareness.
Special thanks to the audio player to support this episode to give you a free trial version for 30 days at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend a redefined book reality, which explores
What is real and what is imaginary of both scientific and philosophical perspective,
Through a series of really awesome lectures. You can get a free 30-day trial at audible.com/asap
The choice is among the wide range! We love them because they are great when you're on
God suffices you and you evil diseases
Translation: Atheer